we left the Democratic party in Florida
in a pile of
ruins they're dead I want to throw to a
clip of this this because you both
repeated a line about you want a
politician who does what he says and
says what he's going to do or flip that
the other way and here are two clips
that we put together just in the last
day or so and let's see if that's what
he's doing here a voter that goes to 10
rallies their vote counts the same as
somebody that's unenthusiastic that then
goes and votes and and we just have to
understand that and people will act like
2020 they're like you know Biden was was
such a disaster but here's the thing I
don't think I don't think anybody voted
for Biden okay they were voting against
Trump that was why they did it I mean
let's just be honest he in he energized
Democrats you could have John Kennedy
walk through the door right now and he
wouldn't energize Democrats as much as
Donald Trump does that's just the
reality what did we do in Florida with
these Democrats we defeated these Dem
Democrats we left the Democratic party
in Florida in a pile of
ruins they're
dead in fact if you look if you go back
2019 2018 the or 2019 2020 the Democrats
had like 300,000 more registrations than
we did as Republicans and partially
because of our leadership during coid
that really started to change so by the
time I got uh reelected in November we
had three ,000 more Republicans than
Democrat and we never had more RS than
D's in Florida history we did that with
me being Governor but here's the best
part 300,000 advantage today that
Advantage is
600,000 we've added another
300,000 advantage in one year I mean are
you kidding me Trump endorsed Paul Ryan
when we were trying to remove him in the
freedom caucus back in 2016 Trump
endorsed McCarthy Trump endorsed
McConnell for reelection in 2020 uh I
didn't do any of those things that was
Trump not me and so here's the thing uh
that is delusional stuff look at what
I've done as Governor okay we fought the
biomed Security State there weren't very
many Republicans willing to do that we
Bann gender transition surgeries for
minors not a lot of Republicans have
been willing to do that we ban Sanctuary
cities we put in E verify how many
people associated with Paul Ryan would
have sent illegal aliens to Martha's
Vineyard uh We've pushed back against
Dei and ESG ban Central Bank digital
currency there's not a single elected
Republican in the country who can match
that record that's why I always say like
backing him it's making my job easy
because I don't think you heard anything
that was that was dishonest I'll let
I'll let you guys get to it but just on
a quick point on whether you can get
Democrats to switch over in Florida when
Ronda santis took over as governor in
2018 Democrats had plus 300 00,000
voters registered it is now plus
600,000 Republicans that's a
900,000 registered voter swing Sarah so
the proof is kind of in the pudding
there right yeah I I agree um he has the
track record to run off of uh obviously
I think the question is there are so
many other factors at play when you look
at the Dynamics of this particular
campaign season uh mostly the idea that
Trump continues to get indicted and I
think that that's just bolstering you
know I have the same um nric reactions
that the Grassroots does when you look
at that and you go well they're doing
that to him I can't believe they're
doing that to him we have to support him
now look at what the left is doing to
him and so I think that you know Ronda
santis is running at this unprecedented
time where uh the left is literally
trying to I believe trying to imprison
one of their political opponents who he
happens to be running against in the
primary and so I think what it comes
down to is Americans are really going to
have to decide what it is that they want
do they want someone that has a proven
track record who's done all the work in
Florida that you just mentioned uh
specifically when it comes to the voter
roles specifically when it comes to
transforming a purple State into a very
heavy red state do you want someone who
says hey you know what I I may not I may
not you know uh pick the battles that
Donald Trump does I may not tweet mean
things all the time I may not take that
you know stance but at the end of the
day I get things done is that what you
want America they're going to have to
decide if they want that or if they just
want the fighter uh you know the the guy
that tweets mean things the guy that
again he had a lot of good track record
a lot of good history as president but
he also as I said before has things he
has to answer for so I would hope that
America would vote on um say what they
mean mean what they say and delivering
results I'm just not convinced that the
average American voter appreciates that
more than they appreciate someone going
on a CNN town hall and you know
attacking Caitlyn Collins the way that
they want them
to